good morning rejects it is bright and
early in the morning 7 a.m. my assing
used to waking up this early but the
rogue one a star wars' trans and the zoo
tired
rogue one a Star Wars story the last
trailer apparently has just dropped
Thank You Good Morning America if I see
him a little off in my speaking my
speech like I am now I'm editing a
sketch it's gonna be up later today I've
been putting a lot of work in at John
and I keep a lookout for that and we're
gonna put it up in a few hours but first
let's watch this quit beating around the
bush
[Music]
hmm June whatever I do
death George detect you see understand I
understand
Wow
aha
[Music]
our rebellion is all that remains to
push back the Empire
I think you might be able to help us
that was the last time you were in
contact with your father what is this
it appears he is critical to the
development of a super weapon
oh why if my father built this thing we
need to find him all right how many do
we need
they aren't requesting a call sign
it's a rogue one we are dealing with is
immeasurable
the Empire has this kind of power what
chance do we have
[Music]
we have rebellions a built on hope
[Music]
hold up this moment the force is strong
you can feel like
take the next choice
[Music]
save the rebellion safety dream wisely a
lot of quotable lines in this trailer
man Mads Mikkelsen or Mickelson mad I
don't know I'm the worst would if I
don't hear someone else pronounce
someone's name I tend to get it wrong
Mads Mikkelsen is really making his
rounds around the Disney World now
Disney World
I know he's in Doctor Strange isn't this
I know from what I read earlier that
he's Jin's father and that he's the one
who sent a transmission that reports
about planning of the Death Star so I'm
assuming he's some like great scientist
who probably got kidnapped early on and
that's what they were showing us in the
trailer was that he probably got
kidnapped by those death troopers and
that he was sort of forced into building
this Death Star and I really like that
touch of the story because it's making
this so much more personal this really
seems to be less about the spectacle
right if there's a lot of spectacle in
the trailer but it seems to be a lot
more about the human drama on the human
emotion the relationships that are
forming here we got to see more Ben
Mendelsohn is whoreson chronic in the
trailer and in my opinion I think he
looks like he's doing a really good job
Ben Mendelsohn to me is an amazing actor
and I don't I haven't seen too many of
his films I really really dug him in the
place beyond the pines and he in this
movie the human emotion seems were
granted in like a human emotion reality
because I know this is all fiction but
he doesn't feel like he's hamming it up
in a so you still get that evil vibe
from him that untrustworthy vibe is he's
the guy who's like pretty much in charge
of building a Death Star because she
really do get a sense for like an evil
genius and I love that touches he
doesn't seem like he's hamming it up or
really chewing up the scenery he has
that subtlety of someone who's cruel but
highly intellectual at the same time I
really like the footage of he got here
of Donnie Yen and Gian like there seems
to be a perfect contrast here because
Donnie and his character is really in
touch with the forest as much more a
spiritual more centered guy who is ready
to kick ass at a moment's notice with
the staff slash blaster which is awesome
I mean one thing I kind of worried about
is that he's only gonna have like one
cool fight scene that they keep showing
little bits of from the trailers because
they cut back to the same fight scene
that we saw in the other trailer it's
just a different moment of that fight in
this specific trailer but it's cool that
we're getting two different Asian actors
in one Star Wars movie and they're part
of the main ensemble I was talking about
John about this yesterday
it really feels that Asian actors have
kind of be getting [ __ ] over a lot
when it comes to certain adaptations
certain roles in the Hollywood and I'm a
Filipino so I support the Asians taking
a stand they both seem to have some
really cool personalities I'm already a
big fan Johnny ends Ip Man films not
from there with John when making sure
I'm saying his name right but I loved
his attitude already like you could tell
this guy's a traumatized dude from my
understanding his homeworld has been
like an Imperial occupied so he has a
real kind of distaste for the Imperial
Army but I'm excited to see the
back-and-forth exchange at him and Don
en have because Donnie ends much more of
a Zen kind of warrior and this guy seems
to be much more rough around the edges
but you can tell there's gonna be like a
definite respect for this guy because
even Donnie yen's
like cracking up at his dry sense of
humor I like that we got two very
different personalities most likely some
of these people are going to die cuz
this takes place right before episode 4
and I don't recall seeing any of these
guys in there I wouldn't be surprised if
they all die but I'm sure at least like
Donnie Yen or Gian when are gonna die I
like what they're doing but k2s oh I
like what they're they're not showing
him that much in the trailers really
because I know like the episode one
everyone hated Jar Jar Binks and then
when people try to defend Jar Jar Binks
they usually attack c-3po I don't know
why I think c-3po is [ __ ] hilarious
that's gonna be interesting to see that
they have like their own you know that
our own Terminator 2 in there terms of
the you know a bad machine that they
reprogram to work for them and to help
the resistance it's exactly for
terminator 2 that's what Armel is that
is Arnold Schwarzenegger's character not
very original Star Wars I really hope
that team plays out a little bit
differently I mean it seems like these
kind of slow
a the group reacting to a different
thing than what gin is saying when she
says we had hope rebellions of built on
hope as it especially did it like sell
me on that was when Donnie Yen was like
like everyone's like you know what she's
got a point she's got a point where you
all can do this because I know Gareth
Edwards had like a pretty significant
dark vision for this specific story and
then there are rumors about it's about
how they reshot it to make it much more
lighter and tone I really feel like
they're trying to make sure that gets
across in this show cuz the other
traders are fairly dark and I was okay
with that and I hope this doesn't get
like corny like that here is everything
I've heard about what Gareth Edwards a
specific vision for this and what he
hopes to achieve with it sometimes those
cheesy moments in this traitors sort of
took it away from me I'm sure what I'm
watching I'm watching the actual phone
we're gonna be like you know all amped
up and really into it it's the way they
cut that moment because it just doesn't
seem like she's said it and that's the
exact reaction that happens in the movie
it looks like they took like a later
part of that meeting and they showed
that reaction and made it look like they
were reacting to that I don't know I'm
not gonna lie I've got all the names of
the new planets that are being
introduced here and I just I don't know
how to pronounce them in the trailer I
think we saw like three specific battle
sequences yo cats I'm filming specific
different things yo what are you doing I
think we saw three specific battle
sequences I mean there was one that took
place at night on land there's another
one at the beach and then there's
another one with a rogue squadron and
you know in space it just really seems
to be like real epic human drama going
on in the midst of the actual battles
like the battle sequences that they're
showing here in the trailer my clad
differently in the movie but the way
they were playing out here they felt
like there was a real heavy weight to
each battle it wasn't just like this is
gonna be a cool scene in the next Star
Wars film this is gonna be an exciting
set piece it seemed like that this is
gonna be some real intense
that is going down like they would even
cut two shots of them in the middle of
the war word you can see there's one
character I mean I can't find it I mean
yeah it looks like the care there is
Ahmed is playing like well I feel like
it's from the beach sequence even laughs
this look on his face like oh [ __ ] this
might be it it's my bean I'm gonna die
but I'm gonna [ __ ] fight anyway and I
love that like triumph a hero there I'm
gonna think about it granted like our
heroes in the Star Wars movies they are
technically a part of the rebellion but
this feels like the first time where I'm
gonna feel a real strong vibe at least
on Miami okay I'm gonna feel really
strong by for the rebellion you know
it's not just about like the
protagonists of the story but I feel
like I'm gonna really root for the
rebellion even though it's a prequel and
you know we know the outcome of things
but it's nice knowing that it's like
instead of just focusing on Luke or on
door ray that I really feel like I feel
like we're gonna develop a strong
connection with the rebellion as a whole
and that's shot to you we're Darth Vader
he's coming through the smoke and he's
like pacing at ben mendelsohn most
likely I get a feeling that if someone
doesn't just shoot Ben Mendelsohn he's
most likely gonna get destroyed by Darth
Vader I feel like we're gonna get Darth
Vader in it like maybe a decent amount
but I feel like Ben Mendelsohn will be
the primary antagonist in this film and
I think it'd be cool if Darth Vader
killed him so far this looks really cool
the other two trailers I thought were
really epic this one definitely has a
really like tugging at the heartstrings
kind of vibe here a little bit more
cheesy inspiring dialogue from gen than
I was expecting because it's it's
showing cuz I you know like her
character is usually a lone warrior and
then she becomes part of this I know
there's gonna be that orator she's you
know feels like she's something more
important she's a big part of this
section of the resistance I feel like
they were showing us more of what she
probably turns into later on in the
movie that I would have liked to have
seen early on this is called rogue one I
know part of the reason why the Tyler
wrote one was to link it to Jin's
character and they were showing her more
as a leader in this trailer which I know
the movie has to get to and it's gonna
do that but I am really excited to see
that like low warrior personality I
think that's kind of cool to watch the
the growth into the
because this trailer was kind of making
it look like she just is that from the
beginning and what I love what this
films doing I know diversity is a thing
that more movies are trying to do this
film is very diverse in terms of its
cast you know you got a British actress
in there you got you know spanic actors
in there you got four Whitacre you got
cool Forest Whitaker all black man in
there you got a couple of Asian dudes in
there yeah I really like the whole cast
you got a robot in there and I feel like
robots having any hate even before they
start taking over the world
yeah Road one december cannot come soon
enough anyway guys if you're new to the
channel subscribe today become a regent
join the rebellion and you can follow us
on social media stuff am i thinking that